منافسه شرسه بتشهد الانتخابات النصفيه
الامريكيه اللي شاغل العالم وتصدره بسببها
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه للتراند
والاخبار والعناوين الانتخابات اللي بدات
امس وانتهت صباح اليوم وكانت الاغلبيه
فيها لصالح الجمهوريين من مجلس النواب
والمنافسه ما زالت على اشدها على مقاعد
مجلس الشيوخ وبين العالم كله
النتائج كمان في ناس جلسه بتترقب نشره
اخبار الماسك اليوميه واذا كان ماسك رح
يكمل في قرار تفعيل العلامه الزرقاء اللي
تاجل اللي بعد الانتخابات تفاديا لموضوع
امتحان الهويه وتسييس للانتخابات لصالح
حزب دون الاخر او يعني على الاقل هذا هو
الشيء المعلن اللي هم قالوه وبعدين النقطه
بالتحديد كانت جدد الامس بسبب تغريده
نشرها ماسك اوصى فيها الامريكيين بالتصويت
للجمهوريين باعتبار انه الرئاسه
لديمقراطيين وارفقها كمان بتغريده الثانيه
ان المنتخب من المستقلين هم اللي بيقرروا
نتائج الانتخابات هذه التغريدات عملت حاله
من الانقسام والجدري في الاراء ففي ناس
شافت انه يعني انت لغيت قرار التنسيق
التوثيق علشان موضوع التسييس وانت جالس
منشور جلس يعني بتنشر وبتكتب منشورات
وتغريدات كلها تسييس وفي ناس شافت لا عادي
ترى مواطن قولوا حق التعبير عن رايه زيه
زي غيره نتيجه هذا الجدل طلع ماسك ابرر
ووضح انه هو طول عمره مستقل ما بيتبعل
للجمهوريين وولد ديمقراطين ولكن تاريخ
الانتخابي لغايه السنه هذه كان مع
الديمقراطيين فانه كان بيصوت لهم ولكن قال
كمان ان هو منفتح على التصويت مره اخرى
للديمقراطيين في المستقبل
بالاضافه لتصدر اسم الماسك الاخبار بسبب
تويتر والتوثيق وغيرها كمان كان في لشركه
السيارات اللي بيمتلكها ماسك اللي هي تسلا
طبعا نصيب من الاخبار اليوم من بعد ما تم
تداول المعلومات انه ماسك باع اسهم في
تسلق بقيمه 4 مليار دولار واللي اظهرت
هيئه الاوراق الماليه والبورسات الامريكيه
انه ماسك مول جزء كبير من صفقات تويتر عبر
بيعوا لاسهم في بلغت قيمتها ما يقارب
ثلاثه مليار دولار
للمستثمرين
انه ماسك بيهتم بالتويتر اكثر منهن هو على
فكره شركه تسلم فقدت نصف قيمتها في السوق
من ابريل الماضي كمان